what's going on reject nation one
division episode four
is here today people excited to check
this out you know what i usually handle
all the intros john why don't you take
this one away
guys 45 seconds our full-length stream
along for this
obviously these reaction highlights we
can only include 10 minutes because the
youtube rules are super stringent so if
you want to see the full length show
sync up with the time code come on over
to our patreon we got a whole bunch of
other shows over there
that have both the option for reaction
highlights as well as the full-length
watch along sync up
included there's a whole bunch of
pictures right now that show you all the
shows that we got
also special thanks to the man eric over
at nerd chronic
for editing this video he edits for
people like iman uh
snow movie he edits for people like emon
snow movie trivia shmo down and a whole
bunch of other people who you probably
love
so big thanks to him and uh now let's
hop into episode four of one division
yeah hit the like button oh could you
also hit that like button and remember
to subscribe and
click that notification bell and uh
follow along with our one division
playlist so that you always know when
another reaction is not
too much now we're way past the woman
tomorrow
sorry guys
what the hell what the hell
whoa she's like handling the reverse
snap herself
oh this is
they're all coming back we don't have
the capacity oh wow
oh damn oh
first thing that happened when i got
back i got knocked over
your mom she died honey
what no oh
oh that's heartbreaking
just like the far from home opening
just as funny that blip
causing all kinds of comedic hygiene
circumstances
in the emcee like killing maria rambo
off screen
oh all that hilarity
really threw you into it now back to
sitcoms
captain monica rambo director tyler
hayward
acting director we have an age of the
day exposition
how are the numbers for the astronaut
training program dismal
astronaut training program fantastic
four there's no easy way to say this
but you're grounded i'm sorry what
go to your room you'd be doing me a big
favor with this fbi thing but if you
need more time no
no keep me updated kevin
it's so hard not to watch one of these
shows without looking at the background
for like
any easter egg yeah
james
yes pardon me sheriff would you mind
repeating your claim about west view to
my colleague here
no such place westview new jersey
doesn't exist that's why i keep telling
your g-man here but he won't listen
oh how weird i see
and um i'm sorry what town are you from
east view
why haven't you gone inside to
investigate because it doesn't want me
to
you can feel it too can't you nobody's
supposed to go in
how eerie
have you tried shooting it
there it is there it is
some sort of energy field
watch it
captain rambo
nuclear biology artificial intelligence
astrophysics i'm a chemical engineer no
one cares
kind of makes you think of the first
thor movie yeah a little bit especially
with the small town vibes and all that
yeah
whoa i mean
whoa what are you getting a colossal
amount of cnbr
we've been told the radiation is within
a safe limit uh it is
for now wait what do you mean
where's the laugh track hey
why isn't this empty without it style
the weird ass victory i need a tv an old
one
like oh yeah i'm getting super like a
lot of first thor vibes right now
these stores will take you straight into
town try to find anything you can on
rambo
top of that
and uh bring these bees with you
little marvel mystery
someone get me a useful visual dammit
who's doing that who's screaming in
agony like that
is that it looks like her look i know
it's been a
crazy few years on this planet but he's
dead right
where's the tenderizer what am i looking
at a damn good
six cop is what you're looking for
quality tv
my equipment registered an extremely
high level of cmbr
that's relic radiation dating back to
the big bang yeah
oh oh
english please oh is this like the first
shot of the
so you're saying the universe created a
situation starring two avengers
it's a working case look at the guy in
the background smiling
that's cool maybe i could get that
coffee now
or not that's cool sexism
there it is there's a shot we
successfully identified two individuals
inside the westview anomaly
let's keep going
she's the star of that 70s show put her
on the board it's a damn good [ __ ]
does that mean toe for graces in this
you no scrolls yeah
this is the this is the board new rock
stars
not the ramen definitely not the boss
lady i met yesterday
what are we looking at here is it an
alternate reality
time travel some cockamamie social
experiment it's a sitcom
i do have an idea so
you've seen that radio on wanda's
kitchen counter right pitch a sitcom to
water
got an idea about two girls who are
broke
agent wu that's mephisto right there
that's the kista in disguise
absolutely what does it look like to you
like a retro version of a sword drone
why'd you colorize it
i didn't let's cut the show on the road
use the same one i hate you joe stupid
this is so cool i love this there's a
whole other level of meta
who's doing the seawander
oh how neat and that song wasn't
it's over mission failure no pay
attention to the commercials
good effort doctor especially to the
commercials
so because yeah there's that shot in the
last episode where she's like looking at
the
radio all mysterious yeah
but that's that didn't appear on their
string it just it just skipped
yeah um
oh that's not good oh no
it's like an all-time jump rope yeah
i haven't seen one of those since school
oh this feels like ambulant
entertainment yeah
how cool
how cool
do you think it's time to call the
doctor because i honestly sounded like
sex noises yeah
twins what a twist
wow this is different
how eerie
wow this is so cool gotta love all the
aspect ratio changes too this is so
cool i'm just your neighbor and how did
you know about ultra
world
oh
yep just just cover that right up
television magic right there where is
geraldine
she had to rush home
oh
this is our home oh
don't worry darling i have everything
under control
she's so scary i know
it's all wonderful damn straight
music is probably low so it doesn't get
blocked just letting you guys know dude
that was wonderful wonderful
wonderful this show has such a great
vision and it does for the future of
marvel
my cheeks are scarlet having made so
many
expressions what a fascinating episode
this one was
so it starts off about monica rambo then
the middle chunk focuses
on jimmy and darcy investigating then it
ends with filling in the gaps of the
ending of
episode three so cool i think like
the biggest takeaway is the
clarification this is all
wanda there's all these theories going
around that bethesda was somehow linked
to this
i got the harkness obviously being
involved here what i loved about those
final moments is you're seeing
wanda you get the sense that she has no
other choice in order for her to have
this life with vision she has no other
choice
but to do this so she's doing certain
actions that come across
like oh my god do not mess with this
person you know like a mama bear or
something or
mama lion you're just like she is
fiercely protective of this home
she has created if you threaten to break
this
fantasy with reality she gets
incredibly defensive for lack of a
better word but i love that when
her fantasies being broken in reality
like peeks through
and in that split moment when vision
does first show back up you know he
looks like how he did
when uh he died in infinity war he looks
like a
like a like a corpse for a while like
it's
almost a zombified vision yeah he's all
pale and
it really is an eerie and unsettling
image
yeah and i love the final moments too of
how monaco was
like it's like she seemed terrified of
her it's wanda it's wanda
wanda's so scary i know
cause like really she's great at playing
those
deadly serious moments and i was really
like even though i knew
monica was at least just gonna get you
know ejected from the
little world there for a moment i was
like oh god they do that
thing where they go into shots that are
sort of new and a little bit of dialogue
we didn't see before and for those split
moments they actually had me really
worried for monica
yeah i mean when wanda injures her you
know he just like thrusts her through a
bunch of walls
through every wall
thrashing through it was just so cool to
see the perspective of how you watch
episode one two and three
in the fantasy eyes of wanda when in the
world she's creating
and then you go back and you're filling
in before the gaps
during and it's neat to see through
wanda's perspective of the first three
episodes like the beekeeper when he
shows up how
through her perspective this show
sitting there like oh my god are these
villains or they the evil ones for
people who have been you know at least
following theories or reading up on
stuff a lot of us were drawing this
conclusion that it would be sword
and that this is really all wanda's
doing but i love the way how the show
plays with the mood and tone of it
because then when you go to this
perspective you're like no these guys
are good
like they just want to figure out what
the hell's going on
missing towns happening and they think
one is in danger in some way
possibly you know i love that moment
with the white board and
it does feel like a new rock star theory
video of like
is is vision alive is this this
why is this sick of like these are
realities or
these are exact topics that i swear
they've done videos
yeah and that a lot of people have done
videos on so it's kind of like a wink at
the audience but it just shows you how
they have no control over this they're
just as clueless as we are as they're
trying to
unpack this mystery it was so fun to see
that opening scene though with the blue
them returning you know i love that and
far from home
you do get like the comedic version of
that and then here you see like the
devastating version to even
think of that thinking of the
consequences
of being gone for five years how many
people has that happened to
of to lose a loved one that's so
traumatizing
and that sets up such an interesting uh
a curious arc of where they would take
monica rambo you know she disappears
she's in the waiting room and
during the surgery uh for her mom right
she said like the surgery went well
yeah and that was pick her up she's
supposed to be discharged that was the
last she heard and then to come back
years later and like learning
all this at once is just so traumatizing
absolutely yeah and just like really
beautifully handled too because that was
such an authentically chaotic and
tense scene just with all the
pandemonium going around the hospital
like they really really
again like because the snap and the blip
and everything is so
much of a meme almost now you know they
really brought
all that gravity back to it in a really
striking way yeah it's like you got
monica here has to live up to the
the legacy that her mom i mean they said
i've founded sword right yeah
established here the ground up and she
founded sword i'm wondering about this
tyler
character his director yeah something
about him
i don't know why you just seem like
someone who might be a bad guy
you seem you're like you're in the
position to be one of those guys who's
like
really calming and trustworthy up front
but then later on we find out oh
switcheroo are you with hydra are you
somebody else but i'm rooting for him
he's got a sexy voice
this felt like a marvel movie more akin
to what we're a little bit more familiar
with like we
kept referencing like the first thor
movie especially or kind of thinking
about a little bit of like civil war
winter soldier i think
because you're dealing with sword but it
feels like shield headquarters in a lot
of ways
having that spy tactical high level
intelligence
department that you're exploring and it
was cool getting jimmy wu back here
i love rental park he's just he's
freaking hilarious and it was neat to
see how
you take him from ant-man on the wasp
you throw him over here and that man of
the wasp i remember him being
such a comedic character yeah like he
was so comedic that you're like how's
this guy
even in the fbi you know he's just such
a goofball then here you
really see how much he does care about
his job he's not just here for comedy he
gets a lot of scenes where he gets to
play it very serious and straight and is
not playing it for jokes like the
the first moment when they do show up at
west view yeah you get those freaking
reveals there too
yeah with the cops and everything and
like the selective amnesia of like well
apparently this town's real and also
tying in with the
you know different boards of the names
of all the people who live there and
like
the roles they've been given you know
getting that little expander on okay
clearly some people are able to perceive
this town but everybody in the immediate
area i guess is
not yeah which shows her the extent of
her
reality warping because she's doing the
reality warping within this
this hub of westview this town that
wanda has taken over
possibly with the help of agatha
harkness and mephisto but let's just
focus on wanda what the show's telling
us right
wanda taking over the town beyond that
though her reality bending skills
extend to people outside apparently they
just can't identify
westview okay so when they're thrusting
in here occasionally the reality starts
to break a little bit
it looked like when monica was geraldine
she really believed she was and then
slowly there's little things
sometimes like how that happens to wanda
little things might happen that's what
triggered her is like oh my i'm not
i'm monica i'm part of sword it doesn't
seem like she was like deep unrecovered
it seemed like her mind was being
manipulated and switched into this realm
i almost wonder if there is something
like that at work where it's like in the
subconscious because you think back to
like that moment with herb and agnes at
the
wall in the backyard and it's almost
like there's a subconscious wanting to
break
beyond the illusion everyone's being fed
or something like that and maybe because
monica
is highly trained it literally came here
to investigate maybe
she was able to break through that much
faster or something like that
yeah and going back to jimmy it's just
so funny to see because in a lot of ways
he is like the marvel audience member
yeah in this episode specifically so
why does it come so happen then darcy
getting sucked into the show it's like
oh they're having twins
all the questions he was asking i'm like
these are all the questions we're all
asking
i love that this turn is a bit more
earnest and a bit more you know just
concerned for him you know when jimmy
has the moment of
did you just mention ultron did you just
mention a reality yeah
crossed back over into art have they
done that before has this happened yet
he was this close to being like hey they
haven't brought a pizza in a few whiles
damn it's been so long oh damn
i thought they forgot about quicksilver
in the mcu what's that now i'm wondering
is that gonna become like a running
joke in the real world is them going
like wait a minute but this
doesn't match up with our reality but
that does the same thing can be said for
darcy
they really have her do the position she
was hired for here not to say that that
wasn't the case in in the thor movies
but she was played a little bit more for
like what kat dennings has hired usually
to do you know to be
funny that's like my main takeaway with
darcy lewis is in the movies
yeah she's funny and she's got some
humor here but it's more focused on her
skills you know and i like the bond and
the chemistry that's forming between her
and randall park i think that's a big
enjoyment factor of this specific
episode as well watching all the
all the little clues that we were
getting before then you're filling in
those gaps
right away and then now it's like the
next episode we're editing
fresh territory so now i'm thinking like
what are what's the structure gonna be
like yeah are we gonna be cutting
back and forth between the sitcom and
sword how would that work with the laugh
track being in there i'm trying to
imagine like what it would be like but
what's that the way to find out
exciting questions to have yeah yeah
it's like the first three are like the
the
setup foundation and then the fourth one
is like the completed foundation and now
i'm like
all bets are off here we are yeah yeah
exactly because i thought with the way
they were handling their mystery that
they would start
giving all these answers a little bit
later they gave it all in this one
episode and
it's cool switching perspectives i love
that you know when you're in wanda's
world
oh my god these people are a threat and
they're scary and then in their world
they're like oh no one is a threat to
yeah what is she doing to these people
they've really woven
like an oddly both super fun and bouncy
but very compelling mystery out of this
that has all those yeah like
paranoid sort of twilight zoney eerie
but that also has in perfect spades the
bouncy marvel sleek production i think
the show's got balls
i mean to do the first three episodes
the way they did and then go episode
four and
completely different you know i think
this is a really
really neat series i'm really in love
with this show a lot
all right guys well what did you think
of this episode leave your thoughts down
below
now the next question to get confirmed
or answered is
is
okay are they going to reveal agatha
hartness and retire to yet what's going
on here
she's gonna start mentoring what's going
on here we got
but i think they got a lot more in store
the fact that we got a few more episodes
left and they revealed this much i'm
like
oh man now we got some crazy [ __ ] to
them
yeah oh dude i love this
guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button if you enjoyed our
reaction
uh go ahead check us out on patreon
speaking of which
fox i just found out fox's real name is
actually
blake blake i like to take you to a lake
and shake it
we're stopping that inside look at what
your name means your name actually means
fair-haired dark well
that's a contradiction i don't know
about that because you know what
your name might mean dark but you bring
a lot of light
into my soul and this
fox foxy foxy blake
boom boom boom boom i like to
say
i like to take the fake dark
i feel like anything i'm saying is
starting to lead down a
very cancelling kind of man
i just want to say thank you blake for
being you absolutely
and um and break a leg stay awake
blake as you make
a bootcake oh i shouldn't have added
this